gráfica la siguiente ecuación de
igualados por x + 2 todo eso al cuadrado
menos 4 déjenme me pasa un lugar donde
pueda trabajar muy bien tenía el
polinomio y es igual a 2 veces x + 2 al
cuadrado menos 4
ahora bien noten que en esta forma
canónica de la ecuación de la parábola
este término de aquí siempre es mayor o
igual a 0
de modo que el signo de todo este
término el término que incluya el 2 está
determinado por el signo de este número
en este caso como es un número positivo
esto siempre va a ser un número mayor o
igual a cero si multiplicó algo más algo
positivo por un número que es mayor o
igual a cero obtengo otro número que es
mayor o igual a cero de modo que a menos
4 siempre le estoy sumando un número
mayor o igual a 0 por lo tanto si lo que
quiero es obtener el número más chico
posible para allá entonces lo que tengo
que hacer es sumar 0
si a -4 le sumo exactamente 0 ese sería
el valor más chico que tomaría esta
expresión de donde puedo concluir que
esta función tiene un mínimo
el mínimo
en qué punto pues para que esta
expresión de que se anule x tiene que
valer menos dos así que x vale menos 2 y
si x vale menos 2 esto se hace 0 y
llévale sólo menos 4
este es un mínimo y de hecho
precisamente es el vértice de la
parábola este es el vértice
así que bueno hagamos una pequeña
gráfica para ver qué está pasando
y pongo mi egg
y por acá pongo mi eje x
y yo sé que la parábola tiene un mínimo
en menos dos menos cuatro que el vértice
está en menos 24 y donde esté ese punto
pues veamos 1 todos ellos de al menos 2
es uno menos 223 menos cuatro yo sé que
la parábola pasa por este punto que es
el menos dos como a menos cuatro y que
aquí es un mínimo de modo que la
parábola se ve algo así
se ve algo así para poderla graficar
completamente voy a hacer una tabla y
vamos a encontrar otros tres valores
para que todas las parábolas se
determinan con tres puntos así que esto
funciona con cualquier parábola veamos
vamos a poner aquí
el valor de x y aquí el valor de y que
es 2 por x2 al cuadrado menos 4
ya sé que la parábola pasa por menos dos
así que menos dos menos cuatro así que
voy a tomar puntos que estén cerca vamos
a tomarnos menos uno menos dos y menos
tres para menos dos que hace que el
valor de g es menos cuatro para menos
uno cuánto es para menos uno sería menos
uno más dos es uno positivo al cuadrado
es 1 2 por 1 es 2 menos 4 sería menos 2
- 2 y para menos tres menos tres más dos
es menos uno que al cuadrado es 12 por
12 menos 4 de nuevo es menos dos así que
yo sé que en menos 1 la parábola pasa
por que igual a menos 2 es decir este
punto allí es el menos uno coma menos
dos y simétricamente para x igual a
menos tres la parábola pasa por menos
tres coma menos 2
entonces nuestra parábola se ve algo así
bueno y ahí escribe al punto pero tenía
que pasar por ese punto entonces vamos a
reacomodar los puntos en el sitio a
estas posiciones bien entonces el
vértice estaba en menos dos menos 422
como a menos cuatro en menos uno la
parábola pasaba por menos uno coma menos
dos y en menos tres la parábola pasaba
por menos 3 - 2 así que esa debe ser la
gráfica en efecto